okay everybody uh thanks for coming here  I'm really excited to hear what your  ideas are for the post-credits scene for  She-Hulk and I know you guys said he has  something with scar so late on me I'm  really excited to see what you all have  what we were thinking was less ger and  more per so we went ahead and put  together this mock-up on what we want  him to look like and the kind of vibe  that we're looking for your idea is to  take a character that if you if you look  at the definition of badass his face  would appear next to it your idea was to  take that character and turn him into  this character who looks like he  meditates first thing in the morning  drinks vegetable powder mixed with  coconut water and wears air walks that's  your idea and and all of you are on  board with this right now I mean yeah  like we we all thought it was a great  idea like everybody here is is on board  with it you're all fired  every last one of you were fired